uh all right security will be ramped up
at many schools across the country today
i know that there are a lot of people
here in the studio including you nate
yeah including our audio engineer mary
noebig whose school the schools that
their children go to have been closed
because of the story that we're going to
share with you right now claims that a
video threatening violence which is
circulating all over social media
schools sent home letters to warn
parents of the claims of shooting and
bomb threats on tick tock cbs news has
not been able to confirm or find the
original video of threats but in a
statement on twitter tick tock said it
is working with law enforcement to
investigate the statement also says the
company handles even rumored threats
with utmost seriousness and that they
have not found evidence of such threats
originating or spreading via tick-tock a
u.s law enforcement official told cbs
news the threat has no known credibility
an fbi spokesperson told us if anyone
sees anything suspicious to report it to
law enforcement immediately that's
essentially what's going on right you
received the letter so did mary from her
school her kids school now we're used to
receiving emails about covet and
protocols as we remain fluent in this
fight against it maybe after school
activities but we received this email
yesterday about
these threats on social media about
school shootings from the high school
that my boys go to and then also my
daughter's middle school and it is it's
heartbreaking that as a parent we have
to receive these emails and then have a
conversation but it's more heartbreaking
for our kids yeah that this is almost
normal right like they have become
callous to what could be empty threats
but why are we in a day and age where
empty threats about school shootings are
something we are dealing with but you
can no longer ignore and you cannot
do you as a parent feel are you
comforted by the fact that even if this
is just a rumored threat the school said
we're not taking any chances yes we're
shutting it down yes and they are
notifying the local authorities and
making sure that even if it is empty a
threat we have authority authorities on
high alert but isn't it unfortunate that
a hoax can rise to the level where
you're disrupting all these people and
all their educations right you would
hope it would be our next that's where
we are because of social media in part
exactly